hey it's Justine and look what we have
here it's the brand new yellow iPhone
Apple just announced this brand new
color for the iPhone 14 and the iPhone
14 plus and we have it here in the
studio with the wonderful yellow themed
lights and my yellow sweatshirt sweater
I don't know let's unbox it
whoa
wow like this looks like a sunflower a
walk in the park a beautiful spring day
the sun like this is honestly I think
this might be my favorite iPhone color
to date like I'm not even like a huge
fan of the color yellow but like this
just freaking look at this I hope that
this is translating on the camera
this color is so pretty I love like the
yellow aluminum on the outer like
everything just matches so perfectly
picture this
but hot pink I'm just saying I'm just
saying I see it
[Music]
this is a very very pretty color Apple
logo have you ever seen one of those
before of course in the box we have a
lightning to USBC our little
instructions with an Apple logo not
yellow one of the new things that they
added this year in the iPhone 14 is
emergency satellite connectivity and
this is such an incredible feature I
actually got a chance to go to Apple and
test this out so if you haven't seen
that video I'll put a link in the
description and also in the end card it
was so awesome to really test this out
because being able to see how the
emergency responders will be able to
communicate with you in case that there
is an emergency and you don't have cell
reception was pretty incredible this is
definitely something that you hope that
you'll never actually have to use but as
someone who is sometimes Off the Grid
this is really helpful to know that just
in case of an emergency I feel like my
iPhone will be there for me so now back
to this yellow color look at that it's
gorgeous
along with this new spring refresh with
the new yellow iPhone they also came out
with some new iPhone case colors Apple
watch bands and I have one of the new
cases here this is the iris case so this
is a much darker purple than the
previous one
that's very pretty so here's the other
color that I had before it's a much
lighter purple I think this might
actually have some makeup on it but it
just just disregard that but it's
definitely a much darker color I'm not
sure if I would pair the purple with a
yellow or actually maybe I would that
looks kind of nice
it's complimenting I mean honestly I
don't want to ever put a case on this
yellow ever this is so pretty so I wish
that I could make this video longer but
I've already reviewed the iPhone 14 the
iPhone 14 pro Max and now this is pretty
much the same phone that we know and
love but just in the color yellow and
I'm excited about it I love that Apple
has been doing these kind of secondary
releases it's always like a little March
surprise it's like hey Justine happy
birthday we decided to release an iPhone
and I'm like great you could have just
got me a cake but not gonna complain
about a new iPhone color there's also 20
new Apple watch bands and air tag
accessories there's even a new Hermes
line they look so cool I've actually
never owned an Irma's Apple watch band I
think I bought one once and then it was
not the right size so I returned it and
when I'm currently rocking right now
I've got the Milanese loop with the gold
Apple Watch series 8. I've been swapping
between the Apple watch Ultra and the
series 8 and it's so great because like
one day I will wear this one put this
one on the charger take the other one
off in the morning and have the app
watch Ultra for the next day so it's
been really fun and it's so easy to
switch between apple watches if you do
have multiple that I never lose steps it
just automatically syncs and updates and
it knows that I have whichever watch on
so I don't know what else to say about
this again I've already made reviews if
you guys want to go watch the full
review of them please do so but here it
is the yellow iPhone 14 and 14 plus I'm
gonna just leave this here and you guys
can Talk Amongst yourselves while you
subscribe like comment and hit the Bell
so you'll be notified when I post new
videos see you later
[Music]